Concernant le souhait que je dois exprimer, je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à quand on est enfant
et que tous vos amis vous demandent quel vœu on ferait si un génie vous demandais --
vous accordait un seul voeu à faire, quel serait-il?
Et j'ai toujours répondu, "Eh bien, je souhaiterais savoir,
avoir la sagesse de savoir exactement quel doit âtre mon souhait".
A ce moment là, vous vous seriez fait avoir, parce que vous sauriez quoi faire comme voeu
et vous n'auriez plus de vœu.
Et comme nous n'avons droit qu'à un seul voeu, à part l'an dernier où ils en avaient trois,
je ne vais pas l'utiliser pour ça.
Donc venons-en à ce que j'aimerais, qui est la paix dans le monde.
Et je me doute de ce que vous pensez.
Vous pensez, cette pauvre fille là,
elle pense qu'elle est à un concours de beauté
Mais ce n'est pas le cas. Elle est au prix TED.
Mais, vraiment, je pense que ce que je souhaite est sensé
et je pense que la première chose à faire pour avoir la paix dans le monde est de faire en sorte que les gens se rencontrent.
J'ai rencontré beaucoup de personnes très différentes dans ma vie
et j'en ai filmé certaines
depuis le cadre d'une start-up Internet à New York, qui voulait conquérir le monde
jusqu'à l'agent de presse militaire au Qatar
qui préférerait ne pas conquérir le monde.
Si vous avez vu le film "Salle de contrôle", qui a été émis,
vous comprendriez mieux pourquoi. Merci.
(Applaudissements).
Whoua! Certains d'entre vous l'ont vu.
C'est génial. C'est génial.
Voilà, ce dont je souhaiterais parler aujourd'hui,
c'est une façon que les gens ont de voyager
de rencontrer les gens différemment,
parce que vous ne pouvez pas voyager aux quatre coins du globe en même temps.
Et il y a longtemps, il y a environ 40 ans,
ma mère avait un correspondant étranger.
Et je vais vous montrer les photos de ce correspondant étranger.
Voici Donna.
Voici Donna avec la statue de la liberté.
Voici ma mère et ma tante qui montrent à Donna comment faire du vélo.
Voici Donna qui mange de la glace.
Et voici Donna qui montre à ma tante une danse philippine.
Et maintenant que le monde se rétrécit, je pense
qu'il est de plus en plus important de connaître les pas de danse des autres,
de se rencontrer, d'essayer de se connaître,
d'imaginer un moyen pour dépasser les barrières,
pour se comprendre, pour comprendre les espoirs et rêves de chacun,
pour comprendre ce qui fait rire ou pleurer les autres.
Et je sais que nous ne pouvons pas tous faire des programmes d'échanges, ou avoir des correspondants étrangers,
et je ne peux forcer tout le monde à voyager.
J'ai déjà discuté de ça avec Chris et Amy,
et ils m'ont dit que ça posait un problème.
Vous ne pouvez pas forcer les gens, et je suis entièrement d'accord avec ça.
Donc nous ne forçons pas les gens à voyager.
Mais j'aimerais évoquer une autre façon de voyager
qui ne nécessite aucun bateau, ou avion
et qui ne nécessite qu'une caméra vidéo , un projecteur et un écran.
Et c'est ce dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui.
On m'a demandé de raconter un petit peu
d'où je viens
et Cameron, je ne sais pas comment tu as fait pour te sortir de là,
mais je pense que construire des ponts est important pour moi,
en raison d'où je viens.
Je suis la fille d'une mère américaine
et d'un père libanais, syrien et égyptien.
Donc je suis le produit de deux cultures qui se rencontrent.
Sans mauvais jeux de mots.
Et on m'a aussi appelée --
en tant qu'égyptienne, libanaise, syrienne, américaine, avec un nom perse,
Crise de la Paix au Moyen Orient.
Donc peut-être que le fait de commencer à prendre des photos était un moyen pour moi
de rapprocher ces deux pans de ma famille
un moyen d'emporter les mondes avec moi, et de raconter visuellement des histoires .
Tout a, plus ou moins, commencé de cette façon,
Mais je pense que j'ai réellement commencé à réaliser le pouvoir qu'avait une image
lorsque je suis allée pour la première fois dans un village de collecte de déchets en Egypte.
Quand j'avais environ 16 ans, ma mère m'a amenée là bas.
C'est une femme qui croit beaucoup dans le service communautaire
et elle avait décidé que c'était quelque chose que je devais faire
et donc je suis allée dans ce lieu, et j'y ai découvert des femmes impressionnantes.
Il y avait des personnes là bas dans un centre
qui apprenaient aux autres à écrire et à lire,
qui vaccinaient contre de nombreuses maladies
que l'on peut attraper quand on trie des détritus.
Et j'ai commencé à enseigner là bas.
J'ai enseigné l'anglais, et j'ai découvert des femmes extraordinaires.
J'ai rencontré des gens qui vivaient à sept dans une pièce,
et qui pouvaient difficilement se payer leur repas du soir,
et qui pourtant vivaient avec force d'esprit et sens de l'humour.
Et juste d'incroyables qualités.
Je me suis plongée dans cette communauté et j'ai commencé à y prendre des photos.
J'ai photographié des mariages, et des personnes âgées dans des familles,
des choses dont les gens voulaient des souvenirs.
Deux ans après avoir pris ces photos,
la conférence du Caire (Conférence de l'ONU sur la population et le développement)
m'a demandé de les montrer lors de cet événement.
J'avais 18 ans, j'étais très excitée.
C'était ma première exposition, et toutes les photos ont été mises là,
et après deux jours, elles avaient toutes été retirées sauf trois.
Les gens étaient très vexés, très en colère
que je montre ces côtés sombres du Caire,
pourquoi donc est-ce que je ne retirais pas l'âne mort du cadre?
Et lorsque je me suis assise, je me suis sentie complètement anéantie,
J'ai regardé ce grand mur vide, avec, vous savez,
trois pauvres photographies, vous savez,
de très belles photographies et là j'ai pensé, j'ai échoué.
Mais j'observais cette intense émotion et ce sentiment intense
que les gens ont ressenti à la simple vue de ces photographies.
Je veux dire, j'étais là, petite fille chétive de 18 ans que personne n'écoutait
et soudainement, j'avais placé ces photos sur ce mur,
et il y avait eu controverse, et les photos avaient dû être retirées.
Et j'ai pu voir la puissance de l'image.
Et c'était incroyable.
Et je pense que la chose la plus importante que j'ai vu là
c'était en fait la réaction de gens qui n'auraient jamais été dans cette zone de déchets
et qui ne verraient jamais que l'esprit humain pouvait s'épanouir
dans des circonstances aussi difficiles.
Et je pense que c'est à partir de ce moment que j'ai décidé
que je voulais utiliser la photographie et la vidéo
pour d'une certaine manière rapprocher les différences, les cultures, rapprocher les gens, traverser les frontières.
Et donc c'est vraiment ce qui m'a lancé.
J'ai travaillé un temps à MTV, et j'ai réalisé un film appelé Startup.com
puis, dans les années 2000, j'ai réalisé quelques films musicaux.
Mais en 2003, quand la guerre en Iraq était sur le point d'éclater,
j'ai eu le sentiment, et ce sentiment était quelque peu surréaliste pour moi,
parce qu'avant que la guerre ne commence, une sorte de guerre médiatique se déroulait.
J'étais en train de regarder la télévision à New York,
et il semblait que seul un son de corde
était diffusé, et qu'il venait --
les reportages du département d'Etat américain étaient destinés aux troupes
et ce dont on avait l'impression avec les informations,
c'était que cette guerre allait être propre, avec des frappes chirurgicales
et que les Irakiens accueilleraient les Américains en libérateurs
et qu'ils leur poseraient des fleurs à leurs pieds dans les rues de Baghdad.
Et je savais qu'en réalité, l'histoire était tout autre,
qui se déroulait au Moyen Orient, où mes parents se trouvaient.
Je savais que c'était une histoire très différente qui était racontée
et je me disais, comment est-ce que les gens peuvent-ils communiquer
avec les autres, alors qu'ils reçoivent des messages très différents
et que personne ne sait ce qu'on raconte à l'autre?
Comment les gens peuvent-ils avoir un la moindre compréhension commune?
ou savoir comment agir ensemble dans le futur?
Donc j'ai su qu'il fallait que j'aille là bas.
Je voulais juste être au centre.
Je n'avais pas de plan. Je n'avais pas d'argent.
Je n'avais même pas de caméra à l'époque.
J'en ai fait venir une
parce que je voulais avoir accès à Al Jazeera,
la chaîne préférée de G.W.Bush
et un endroit dont j'étais particulièrement curieuse parce que
de nombreux gouvernements du monde arabe le détestent
et que certaines personnes du gouvernement américain
surnommait le porte-parole d'Ousama Bin Laden.
Donc, je pensais, cette chaîne détestée
par tant de personnes, doit être en train de faire quelque chose de bien.
Je dois voir ce qu'il en est.
Et je voulais aussi voir le centre de commande,
qui se trouvait à 10 minutes de là, et ainsi,
je pouvais savoir comment ces informations étaient créées
du côté arabe s'adressant au monde arabe,
et du côté américain et occidental s'adressant aux Etats-Unis.
Et lorsque je me suis rendue dans ce pays, et que je me suis installée là bas
et que j'ai rencontré ces personnes qui étaient au centre de tout ça,
et que j'ai discuté avec ces personnages,
j'ai rencontré des gens surprenants, des personnes très complexes.
Et j'ai envie de partager avec vous un petit peu de cette expérience de
quand on s'assoit auprès de quelqu'un et qu'on le filme, et qu'on l'écoute,
et qu'on lui accorde plus de 5 secondes de temps de parole,
alors l'incroyable complexité de cette personne émerge.
Sameer Khader: la routine.
Irak, puis Irak, et enfin Irak.
Mais entre nous, si on m'offre un poste chez Fox, je le prends.
Pour changer le cauchemard arabe en rêve américain.
J'en rêve toujours
Peut-être que je ne pourrai jamais le faire.
Mais j'ai des projets pour mes enfants.
Quand ils finiront leur lycée, je les enverrai aux Etats-Unis pour qu'ils puissent étudier là-bas.
Je paierai leurs études.
Et ils resteront là-bas.
Josh Rushing: La nuit où ils ont montré les prisonniers de guerres et les soldats morts,
Al Jazeera a montré ces images,
ce fut très puissant parce que les Etats-Unis ne montrent pas ce genre d'images.
La plupart des informations aux Etats-Unis ne montre pas d'images très sanglantes
celles-ci montraient des soldats américains en uniforme éparpillés sur le sol,
un sol froid de carreaux.
Et c'était révoltant,
absolument révoltant.
Ça m'a rendu malade.
Et ce qui m'a marqué, c'était que la nuit précédente
il y avait eu un bombardement à Basra,
et Al Jazeera avait montré des images de ces gens.
Et ces image-là étaient tout aussi horribles, voire plus, que ne l'étaient celles-ci.
Et je me souviens avoir vu ces images dans les bureaux d'Al Jazeera
et m'être dit, "Whoa, c'est choquant.
C'est terrible".
Puis, je suis parti et je suis sans doute aller dîner ou faire quelque chose.
Et ça ne m' a pas affecté plus que cela.
Donc, l'impact que ça a eu sur moi, a été de réaliser que
je voyais juste des gens de l'autre côté
et les gens des bureaux d'Al Jazeera
ont du ressentir ce que j'avais ressenti cette nuit-là.
Et ça m'a profondément bouleversé,
plus que je n'ai été bouleversé la nuit précédente.
Cela m'a fait détester la guerre.
Mais cela ne me fait pas encore croire que nous sommes dans un monde où l'on pourrait vivre sans guerre.
Jehame Noujaim: J'étais très émue par la façon dont le film a été reçu,
car nous ne savions pas s'il pourrait sortir là bas.
Nous n'avions pas de subventions pour cela.
Nous eu une chance incroyable que ce film soit sélectionné,
et quand nous avons fait visionner le film à la fois aux USA et dans les pays arabes,
nous avons eu des réactions tellement incroyables
C'était impressionnant de voir combien les gens étaient émus par ce film.
Dans les pays arabes, ce n'est pas tant le film qui a ému,
mais les personnages.
Je veux dire, Josh Rushing était cette personne incroyablement complexe
qui réfléchissait aux choses.
Puis, j'ai fait visionner ce film au Moyen Orient
et les gens ont dit qu'ils souhaitaient rencontrer Josh.
D'une certaine façon, ils nous a redéfini comme une population américaine.
Les gens ont commencé à me demander, mais où est cet homme maintenant?
Al Jazeera lui a offert un emploi.
Et d'un autre côté, Sameer, vous savez,
était également un personnage assez intéressant à voir pour les pays arabes
parce qu'il illustrait toutes les complexités de cette relation d'amour et de haine
que le monde arabe entretient avec l'Occident.
Aux Etats-Unis, j'ai été frappée par les motivations,
les motivations positives des citoyens américains,
quand ils ont vu le film.
Vous savez, nous sommes critiqués à l'extérieur parce que nous nous sentons,
parce que nous coyons que nous sommes les sauveurs du monde dans une certaine manière,
mais la contrepartie de ceci est que,
quand les personnes voient ce qui se passe à l'étranger
et voient les réactions que les gens ont par rapport à notre politique extérieure,
nous pensons que cette puissance,
nous avons l'impression que nous devons avoir le courage de changer les choses.
Et je me suis rendue compte de ceci auprès du public
Cette femme est venue me voir après la projection et m'a dit: "vous savez,
je sais que c'est fou, mais j'ai vu les bombes chargées dans les avions,
j'ai vu les militaires sortir partir pour la guerre.
Mais on ne comprend pas la colère que les gens ont contre nous
tant qu'on ne voit pas les personnes dans les hôpitaux et les victimes de guerre,
et comment nous sortir de cette bulle?
Comment comprendre ce que l'autre pense?
Maintenant, je ne sais pas si un film peut changer le monde,
mais je sais que ça commence, je connais la puissance,
je sais que ça fait réfléchir les gens sur comment changer le monde.
Maintenant, je ne suis pas philosophe,
donc je pense que je ne devrais pas approfondir là-dessus mais plutôt vous montrer,
laissons le film parler de lui-même et vous emmener dans cet autre monde.
Parce que je crois qu'un film peut vous faire traverser des frontières.
J'aimerais que vous vous asseyiez, et que vous vous laissiez pendant quelques minutes,
emmener dans un autre monde.
Et ces quelques séquences vous emmènent au coeur de
deux des plus difficiles conflits auxquels nous sont confrontés aujourd'hui.
Homme 1 : à partir du moment où il y a de l'injustice, quelqu'un doit faire un sacrifice!
Femme 1 : Ce n'est pas un sacrifice, C'est une vengeance!
Si vous tuez, il n'y a pas de différence entre victime et occupant.
Homme 1 : si vous avions des avions, nous n'aurions pas besoin de martyrs, c'est la différence.
Femme : La différence c'est que l'armée israelienne est toujours plus forte.
Homme: Alors, soyons égaux devant la mort.
Nous avons toujours le Paradis.
Femme: Il n'y a pas de Paradis! Ca n'existe que dans votre tête!
Homme: Dieu vous pardonne, dieu vous pardonne!
Que dieu vous pardonne.
Si vous n'étiez pas la sœur d'Abu Azzam…
De toute façon, je préfèrerais encore avoir le paradis dans ma tête que vivre dans cet enfer!
Dans cette vie, nous sommes morts de toute façon.
Homme: Nous choisissons l'amertume seulement si l'alternative est encore plus amère.
Femme: Et nous? Ceux qui restent?
Gagnerons-nous de cette façon?
Ne voyez-vous pas que ce que vous faites est en train de nous détruire?
Et que vous prenez Israel comme alibi pour continuer?
Homme: Donc, sans alibi, Israel arrêterait?
Femme: Peut-être. Nous devons faire de cette guerre une guerre morale.
homme: Et comment faire, si Israel n'a pas de morale?
Femme: Fais attention!
George: Ma femme Ayelet m'a appelé et m'a dit:
"Il y a eu un attentat suicide à Tel Aviv".
Ayelet: Qu'est-ce que vous savez sur les blessés?
Nous recherchons trois filles.
George: Nous n'avons aucune information.
Ayelet : Une est blessée ici, mais nous n'avons pas entendu parlé des trois autres.
George: J'ai dit "OK, c'est Bat-Chen, c'est ma fille".
"Etes-vous sûre qu'elle est morte?"
Ils ont dit que oui.
Tzika: Ce jour-là, vers 6,30,
je conduisais ma femme et mes filles au supermarché.
Quand nous sommes arrivé là bas….
nous avons vu trois jeeps militaires israeliennes garées de l'autre côté de la rue.
Quand nous avons dépassé la première jeep,
ils ont ouvert le feu sur nous.
Et ma fille de 12 ans Christine
a été tuée dans la fusillade.
Tzvika: Je suis le directeur ici.
George: Mais y a-t-il un professeur qui est responsable?
Tzika: Oui, j'ai des assistants.
Je travaille avec des enfants tout le temps.
Tzika: Au début, je pensais que c'était une idée bizarre.
Mais après avoir réfléchi logiquement là-dessus,
je n'ai trouvé aucune raison pour ne pas les rencontrer
et leur faire comprendre notre souffrance.
George : De nombreuses choses m'ont touché.
Nous voyons qu'il y a des palestiniens qui souffrent beaucoup, qui ont perdu leurs enfants,
et qui continuent à croire dans le processus de paix et la réconciliation.
Si nous, qui avons perdu ce qui est le plus précieux, pouvons parler ensemble,
et aller vers un meilleur futur,
alors tout le monde devrait faire la même chose également.
Homme: La chanson est quelque chose que nous avons échangé avec les gens
qui sans ça n'auraient pas compris d'où nous venons.
Vous pouvez leur faire un long discours politique
ils ne comprendraient toujours pas.
Mais, je vous dis, quand vous finissez cette chanson,
les gens se diront "Mon dieu, je sais d'où vous venez, vous les noirs.
Je sais d'où vous venez
Mort à l'apartheid!"
Narrateur: C'est à propos de la lutte pour la libération
Ça parle de ces enfants qui sont allés dans les rues,
en se battant, en criant, "Libérez Nelson Mandela!".
Ça parle de ces syndicats qui ont posé leurs outils
et qui ont exigé la liberté.
Oui! Oui!
Liberté!
Jehane Noujaim: Je pense que tout le monde a ressenti en étant assis dans une salle de cinéma,
dans une salle sombre avec d'autres inconnus, qu'ils étaient en train de regarder un film très puissant,
et qu'ils avaient le sentiment de vivre une transformation.
Et ce dont je parle, c'est....
ce dont j'aimerais discuter, c'est comment nous pourrions utiliser ce sentiment
pourvraiment créer un mouvement à partir du film?
Il y a, je veux dire, j'ai écouté les présentations
de quelques conférences, and Robert Wright a dit hier
que si nous pouvons apprécier l'humanisme d'une autre personne,
alors ils peuvent apprécier le nôtre.
Et c'est ce dont on parle.
Il s'agit de connecter des personnes à travers un film,
de faire que ces voix indépendantes s'élèvent d'ici.
Maintenant, Josh Rushing a effectivement quitté l'armée
et travaille chez Al Jazeera,
donc son sentiment est qu'il est sur Al Jazeera International parce qu'
il pense qu'il peut effectivement utiliser ce moyen de communication
pour combler les différences entre l'Orient et l'Occident.
Et c'est impressionnant.
Mais j'ai commencé à réfléchir à des moyens
de donner du pouvoir à ces voix indépendantes,
de donner du pouvoir à ces réalisateurs,
de donner du pouvoir à ces personnes qui essaient de se servir de ce film pour changer les choses.
Et il y a des organisations incroyables
qui sont là-bas, et qui font déjà ça.
Il y a Witness, dont vous avez entendu parlé avant.
Il y a Just Vision, qui travaillent avec les palestiniens et les israeliens
qui travaillent ensemble pour la paix, et qui documentent ce processus,
et qui procèdent à des interviews et qui utilisent ce film
pour amener le Congrès à dire que c'est un outil puissant,
pour montrer que c'est une femme dont la fille est morte dans une attaque,
et que cette femme pense qu'il existe des moyens pacifiques de résoudre ceci.
Il y a Working Films et Current TV,
qui est une plate-forme incroyable qui permet aux gens du monde entier,
de mettre leur, oui c'est génial.
J'ai vu ceci et je suis juste, je suis impressionnée par
ce potentiel de rassembler les voix du monde entier
des voix indépendantes du monde entier,
et de créer une vraie télévision démocratique et mondiale.
Que pouvons-nous faire pour créer une plate-forme pour que ces organisations,
créent une certaine impulsion,
pour que tous les gens du monde soient impliqués dans ce mouvement?
J'aimerais imaginer l'espace d'une seconde, imaginons un jour,
où tous les gens du monde se rassemblent.
Vous avez des villages, des villes et des cinémas de tous les coins du monde
qui se rassemblent, et s'asseyent dans l'obscurité,
et partagent l'expérience communautaire de regarder un film,
ou plusieurs films, ensemble.
Regarder un film qui peut peut-être mettre en lumière
un personnage qui se bat pour vivre, ou juste
un personnage qui défie les stéréotypes,
qui plaisante, qui chante une chanson.
Des comédies, des documentaires, des court-métrages.
Cette puissance étonnante peut être utilisée pour changer les gens
et pour créer des liens entre eux, pour franchir les frontières
et pour faire en sorte que les gens sentent qu'ils vivent une expérience commune.
Donc si vous imaginez ce jour où partout dans le monde,
vous avez des cinémas aux quatre coins du monde, où nous projetons des films.
Si vous imaginez
projeter des films depuis Times Square jusqu'à Tahir Square, au Caire,
le même film à Ramallah, le même film à Jérusalem.
Vous savez, nous pouvons même utiliser, nous en avons parlé à un de mes amis
un côté de la Grande Pyramide
et de la grande muraille de Chine.
Voilà, ce que vous pouvez imaginer est sans fin,
les endroits où l'on peut projeter des films
où l'on peut développer une expérience communautaire.
Et je crois que si un jour, si nous pouvons créer ce moment,
ce jour-là pourra créer une impulsion pour toutes ces voix indépendantes.
Il n'y a pas un seul endroit,
il n'y a pas une seule organisation qui connecte
les voies indépendantes du monde pour aller là-bas,
et pourtant j'entends à travers cette conférence
que le plus grand danger de notre avenir est (le manque) de compréhension de l'autre
et d'avoir un respect mutuel pour l'autre, et pour franchir les frontières.
Et si un film peut faire ça,
si nous pouvons avoir tous ces différents endroits dans le monde
pour regarder les films ensemble, ce pourrait être un jour incroyable.
Donc nous avons déjà créé un partenariat, développé à travers TED,
quelqu'un de la communauté TED,
John Camen, m'a présentée à
Steven Apkon, de Jacob Burns Film Center.
Et nous avons commencé à prévenir tout le monde.
Et la semaine dernière, il y a eu tellement de gens qui nous ont répondu
depuis Palo Alto, en passant par la Mongolie, jusqu'en Inde.
Il y a des gens qui veulent faire partie de cette journée mondiale du film
et qui veulent être capable de fournir une plate-forme pour que des voix indépendantes
et pour que des films indépendants sortent de là.
Maintenant, nous avons pensé à un nom pour ce jour,
et j'aimerais le partager avec vous.
Le moment le plus étonnant de tout ce processus
a été de partager de idées et des désirs,
et donc je vous invite à réfléchir sur comment faire
comment ce jour peut-il avoir un écho dans notre avenir?
Comment pouvons-nous utiliser la technologie pour faire que ce jour ait un écho dans notre avenir,
de façon à ce que l'on construise une communauté
et que nous fassions que ces communautés travaillent ensemble, par Internet?
Il y eut un jour, il y eut une époque, il y a bien des années,
où tous les continents formaient un bloc.
Et on appelait cette masse Pangée.
C'est pour cela que nous aimerions appeler la journée du film Journée du Cinéma Pangée.
Et si vous imaginez juste
que tout ces gens dans ces villes regarderaient,
alors je pense que nous pouvons vraiment faire un mouvement
de façon à ce que les gens se connaissent mieux les uns les autres.
Je sais que c'est vraiment intangible, de toucher les cœurs et les âmes des gens,
mais c'est la seule façon que je connaisse qui nous permette de faire ceci,
la seule façon que je connaisse pour parvenir
à atteindre le cœur et l'âme de quelqu'un est de leur montrer un film.
Et je sais qu'il y a des réalisateurs indépendants et des films
qui pourraient faire en sorte que ça se produise.
Et le voilà mon vœu.
Donc je pense qu'il faut que je vous énonce ma phrase avec mon vœu,
mais je pense que nous n'avons plus le temps pour cela.
Chris Anderson: C'est un vœu incroyable.
Pangea Cinema - le jour où le monde se rassemble.
JN: C'est plus tangible que la paix dans le monde, et certainement plus immédiat.
Mais ce serait le jour où le monde se rassemblerait à travers un film,
la puissance d'un film.
CA: Mesdames et Messieurs, Jehane Noujaim.